- Le soleil attendait
les habitants de Kiev, ce matin.
Ils n'avaient pas mis le nez
dehors ds s s 48 heures.
Mais, ce n'est pas ce qu'ils ont
d'abord remarqué à l'horizon.
Missile russe délibérément
lancé sur des appartements,
comme disent les Ukrainiens;
erreur de cible du système
de défense anti-aérien,
comme ont riposté les Russes.
Yuri Zaika, un colonel
à la retraite, a été réveillé
en stupeur par l'explosion
dans l'édifice qui fait face
au sien, mais il vient le voir
pour la première fois.
Il préfère croire à une erreur.
"Je pense que c'est une
tragédie. Pendant la Deuxième
Guerre mondiale, on pouvait
comprendre qui étaient
nos ennemis. Mais là,
ce sonfrfrfrfrères, les frères
avec qui nous avons combattu
contre le fascisme. Je ne peux
toujours pas croire que c'est
la rJeJeJeJeJe préfère le voir
comme une erreur. Et bien sûr,
je souhaite la paix."
"Pour avoir la paix
il faut mieux faire la guerre",
croit le leader du Parlement,
lui aussi sorti de son bunker
pour constater les dégâts.
- Stop Putin now.
t t t t troqué le costume-crave
pour le kaki militaire.
"On n'a plus beaucoup de temps.
Le temps, ce sont des enfants
morts. Non, pas morts,
se corrige-t-il, mais
des enfants tués, des femmes
tuées, des civils. C'est
des infrastructures qui sont
détruites. Je veux demander
à tout le monde de cesser
les procédures bureaucratiques
et d'agir."
Tout juste après notre
rencontre, Ruslan Stefanchuk
retrouvait le président
Volodymyr Zelinsky pour
signer une demande officielle
d'adhésion de l'Ukraine
à l'Union européenne.
48 heures de couvre-feu,
ça veut aussi dire que
les provisions à la maison
sont à sec. Depuis ce matin,
les gens font la queue
pendant des heures pour pouvoir
se procurer quelques biens
essentiels dans le peu de
supermarchés qui ont ouvert
leurs portes aujourd'hui.
Ils ont patienté,
sans broncher, pendant plus
de trois heures, ici.
Ils n'en ressortent
qu'avec l'essentiel, parce
qu'il faut bien tous tenir.
(bombardements)
À Kharkiv, les combats
ont été brutaux, aujourd'hui.
La deuxième ville d'Ukraine,
près de la frontière russe,
a été prise pour cible
par les bombardements russes.
Au moins 11 personnes y ont
été tuées, selon le gouverneur
régional. Impossible de secourir
la population sous les bombes.
"Aujourd'hui nous a démontré
que ce n'est pas seulement
une guerre, mais le meurtre
de notre peuple ukrainien",
a déclaré le maire
dans cette vidéo.
L'ONU s'inquiète d'une escalade
des opérations russes qui
conduisent, à leur tour,
à une escalade des violations
des droits de l'homme.
À Kiev, la chasse aux
infiltrés, aux saboteurs,
aux collaborateurs reste
constante. On les attend
surtout de nuit, mais on reste
sur les nerfs à tout instant.
C'est en grande partie
aux forces de défense
territoriales, qui reçoivent
encore des volontaires tous
les jours, qu'il revient
de les intercepter.
"Le moral est bon",
dit ce réserviste qui ne
comprend pas que le monde
s'étonne que les Ukrainiens
résistent encore à une armée
plus imposante.
"Plus grand ne veut pas dire
plus fort", dit ce capitaine.
"Nous sommes plus motivés,
nous nous battons pour notre
pays. Eux, quand ils rencontrent
de la résistance, ils perdent
le moral. Ils ne veulent pas
mourir. Nous, ça ne nous
fait pas peur de mourir."
"Mourir s'il le faut", dit-il,
pour que plus aucun enfant,
comme ce garçon de 13 ans,
ne soit gravement blessé
par les tirs et les explosions
qui pleuvent sur l'Ukraine.
Et pour rendre une certaine
normalité, ici, dans le plus
important hôpital pédiatrique
du pays.
Certains diront d'eux qu'ils
sont des victimes collatérales.
Il serait peut-être plus
juste de parler des oubliés
de la brutalité des grands.
Depuis cinq jours, chaque
fois que les sirènes d'alerte
retentissent au-dessus de Kiev,
ils se retrouvent ici,
dans le sous-sol de l'hôpital.
Kiril et ses petites copines
souffrent de leucémie.
Leurs corps fragilisés par
la maladie et les traitements
de chimiothérapie, ils devraient
être en isolement stricte.
Ce n'est plus possible.
Marina, la maman de Kiril
est rongée d'inquiétude.
Il doit subir un traitement
demain. Une fois lancé,
impossible de l'arrêter.
Trois heures à prier pour
que les sirènes se taisent.
"Nous avons déjà notre guerre
avec le cancer, dit-elle, et là,
encore ça."
"Je souhaite que le monde
entier puisse contribuer à
ce que ça se termine le plus
tôt possible."
(sanglots)
Ce ne sera pas pour cette nuit,
Marina. Sitôt le jour tombé,
Kiev a de nouveau été ébranlée
par de puissantes explosions.
Ici Marie-Eve Bédard,
Radio-Canada, Kiev